he admitted to wanting to kill ethan
he's just like me then cut it short at
finding the psycho's trophies that's
enough you don't have to do any of this
with him i'm not forcing any ideas on
harrison
i want to help him
just like harry helped me
hey guys pete here today i'll be doing a
breakdown of dexter new blood episode 9.
a lot happened in the family business it
had a little bit of something for
everyone and it was a great episode
things ended on a win for dexter and
harrison but there are still a lot of
ways things could go wrong for them in
this finale that's coming up it felt
like a penultimate episode and not just
for this season but for the series so
i'll be recapping everything that
happened and where that leaves us going
into the finale right after this quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
dexter new blood episode 9 yet then this
video won't be for you and with that out
of the way let's get into it the episode
starts with a flashback to mr wiggles
playland in florida it's a part of
dexter explaining what he does saying
guilty people slip through the cracks of
the justice system every day you realize
this is coming from a conversation with
harrison when he mentions the dark
passenger harrison is obviously
unfamiliar with the term but he
understands the sentiment behind it
dexter reveals that he also saw his
mother killed when he was young finally
delivering the payoff we've been waiting
for and they connect there with all that
goes along with that and it leads to an
introduction to harry's code he explains
it in detail as he's recounting the mr
wiggles situation and emphasizes that
his father gave him a way to channel the
dark passenger and use it for good
things get complicated when dexter tries
to frame what he's doing as effective
while trying to keep the fact that he
kills people out of the explanation you
see that he struggles with the idea of
telling him the truth through his back
and forth with deb and he decides not to
do it harrison compares what he does to
batman and dex says he prefers the dark
defender which is a nice call back to
season two it's a lot to process so he
tells harrison he should get some sleep
and then he slips out to take care of
elric's body one more gift to wrap him
plastic as he's taking care of that he
thinks about how there will be more
questions coming from harrison and it's
worth mentioning that both this and the
mr wiggles sequence were a great way to
recapture some of what made the original
series so compelling it's a nice treat
for fans right down to the original
soundtrack and it has a sense of things
coming full circle at the end of the
series as he's cutting up the body deb
points out that it's pretty screwed up
that he watched his mother get chopped
up in a shipping container and does the
same thing to his victims he points out
that harrison faced his trauma by arming
himself with a straight razor the same
weapon used to kill his mother what can
he say they are what they are it makes a
transition to angela who is still
looking into the bay harbour butcher
case she's looking at images from
lundy's investigation which is fitting
because dexter just did the same thing
to a body at the summer camp she notices
an injection site mark in one of the
photos and takes a closer look at that
before she gets interrupted by audrey at
the cabin harrison wakes up and you see
that dexter made it back in time to set
up his presence the big one's a rifle
and this allows him to introduce the
idea of doing things to blend in he
doesn't use guns in relation to the dark
passenger but since all of his friends
from school have guns it makes sense for
him to have one too they go outside and
shoot it harrison is a natural i guess
he follows more in deb's footsteps
rather than dexter's and he asks if kurt
tried to kill him because dexter was
going after him he tells him yes and
that kurt is a serial killer who's been
killing women for 25 years he explains
that he can't tell angela because he
doesn't have any proof and besides he's
already been arrested for one murder and
he got away with it he says he just
found out about it and harrison accepts
this idea of vigilante [ __ ] where they
can't go to the authorities but it's
important to remember that dexter is
leaving something major out here he's
not telling him the reason he can't go
to the cops is because he actually
killed matt he says that he does have a
plan and he hopes that harrison will ask
him what it is and if he can help but
instead he remembers that he has a
present for his dad and he gives him a
drawing he did of deb he gets introduced
to the christmas sweater tradition and
they head over to angela's place to
exchange gifts
she is suspicious of dexter but he
doesn't pick up on it audrey on the
other hand brings up that she thinks
that harrison seems happier everyone
except for angela is having a good time
and dexter's gift doesn't really help at
all but he still thinks to himself a
successful christmas surrounded by
family and then everyone's surprised
when the doorbell rings and even more
surprised when it turns out to be kurt
there's an awkward exchange between kurt
and the morgans and then after he leaves
they say they have to go too audrey and
angela think it's weird but they have no
idea what's going on since kurt didn't
run harrison asks if they can go after
him like mr wiggles dexter says they
have to find proof and that serial
killers usually keep trophies and he
thinks that kurt keeps his trophies on
his property near his cabin while
they're using the drone to scope out
kurt's property harrison confesses to
setting the whole thing up with ethan in
episode 4. not only did he want to get
away with it but he thought it might
even make him look like a hero although
dexter already knew this it is
indisputable proof that he acts out on
his violent urges he mentions that he's
been thinking about mr wiggles and
doesn't know if scaring him seems like
justice when dexter asks what that would
look like he tells him that he started
to have fantasies about killing trinity
with his own razor when he was about 12
years old they noticed a vent where kurt
disappeared after he ran away and
decided to come back after dark to check
it out angela had visited the vet and
found out that dexter came in for
ketamine later as she's at home
listening to molly's bay harbor butcher
episode she gets a call from dexter
saying they won't be able to come over
because they're bonding the podcast
includes molly's belief that they got
the wrong man when they arrested james
doakes she asked audrey what she thinks
and she's just glad that they live in
the sticks away from that sort of thing
ha ha and then angela tries to call
molly but her number goes straight to
voicemail as dexter is preparing his
knives we see him continue to struggle
over really telling harrison the truth
as deb begs him not to for me this is
where the episode got really good and i
think him saying i'm not forcing any
ideas on harrison i want to help him
just like harry helped me sets things up
nicely to start moving into the ending
that brightly points out that there were
alternatives and she gets a reaction
when she suggests that prison might have
been better dexfire's back you think
prison would be better whose side are
you on harrison was born in blood his
dark passenger pushes him to hurt others
this path is the only way the acting
here is tremendous by michael c hall and
jennifer carpenter and she delivers the
best moment in the series so far when
she looks at him and says and you
[ __ ] love it
dexter and harrison arrive at kurt's
cabin in the atv they discover the
entrance and he gives harrison the
chance to stay outside to keep watch but
he wants to see it for himself they
notice a camera that's rigged to an
alarm to notify kurt if someone breaks
in and dexter trips it on purpose to let
him know that all his secrets are out it
turns out he had shown up at their cabin
right after they left to try to burn
them out his plan was to torch the place
and then shoot them as they ran away
trying to escape he gets the
notification and sees them entering his
bunker just as he's starting to realize
that no one is coming out of this
burning cabin inside the bunker they see
his embalming area and then they
discover his trophies he keeps the
entire preserved bodies of his victims
in display cases and there are a lot of
them when they get to the end of the
hall we see that molly was who kurt was
embalming when he was talking to elric
on the phone in the last episode as her
body is on display amongst the others as
he looks at her harrison gets emotional
and says he's been getting away with
this for years so many women dead until
you found him after a pause he continues
saying you killed wiggles didn't you deb
makes one last plea and then dexter
walks over to his son and while looking
him in the eye says i did and i took
care of arthur mitchell to trinity i
killed him for what he did to your
mother harrison takes that all in and
then adds that kurt needs to die too
dexter gives him a kiss on the forehead
and this is in a way everything he's
always wanted angela goes looking for
molly and learns that she checked out
but the man she talks to didn't see her
leave the key was just left on the bed
with a note and when she checks the safe
they discover that her camera and
recorder were still inside saying she
knows that molly would never leave
behind
knowing his secret is out kurt rushes
home in an effort to leave town and as
he's getting ready to do that harrison
distracts him as dexter sneaks up and
knocks him out in the typical fashion
they prepare a kill room in front of his
trophies dex explains the plastic and
how important it is not to leave any
clues behind and harrison asks him how
many times he's done this he says it's
in the hundreds and then checks for a
response and harrison is actually
impressed he says wow that means you've
saved thousands of innocent people and
they share a smile before he wakes kurt
up he tells harrison if there's any
moment where he doesn't feel up to it
just go ahead and go outside once kurt
gets his bearings after they wake him up
he takes responsibility for everything
and i mean he does it in a really
strange way it feels like he's a bit too
eager to do that considering the
circumstances and it makes you wonder if
he's trying to cover something up he
does explain his motivations insisting
that he didn't kill the women he
actually saved them they were all just
runaways and he picked them up and he
offered them a safe place to stay but
that was never enough they always wanted
to go back out there where he thought
they would be the victims of trauma so
he would preserve them rather than
letting them go dexter says that he
wasn't trying to save anyone that it was
all about power and as he's accusing him
of loving the power he had over them and
how it fed the darkness that was inside
of him it sounds a lot like he's talking
about himself kurt does get some shots
in before they put him down he asks if
they're a father and son vigilante team
and he admits that he's jealous and that
he did wish that his son was more like
harrison that leads to the truth about
matt's death coming out and that he
tried to kill harrison in an act of
revenge dexter is quick to say that matt
fit the code and that he escaped justice
because his dad covered up for him but
kurt laughs this off saying wait a
minute that's your rationale for killing
people some kind of [ __ ] justice
code and then he gets a glove shoved
into his mouth and that's followed by a
knife through the heart again he asks
harrison if he's all right and he gives
him the option to go outside because he
still has to dispose of the body
initially he says he's fine but he
starts to lose his cool as his dad is
chopping kurt up and as some blood on
the ground starts to flow in his
direction he has flashbacks to rita's
death and that freaks him out enough
that he decides to leave he looks really
affected and he just remains there
waiting under the blood moon and it's
definitely possible that he got blood on
his boot before he left they go to the
incinerator and dex tells him that
everyone in iron lake will think kurt
fled when they see that he packed his
bags ransacked his place and took all
the money out of the safe harrison says
that his dark passenger is quiet and his
father says that's how it works that's
how we keep it under control and
harrison adds that the world's a better
place for it they head home feeling
pretty good and then they find out about
the fire angela and the police are there
he sticks with his cover story that they
were out hiking and they just lost track
of time and then audrey insists that
they come and stay with them as they're
coming inside the house angela notices
that someone left an envelope in her
mailbox and inside she finds a note that
says jim lindsey killed matt caudwell
with some of his surgical screws inside
she looks over at jim who's making
breakfast and gives him a fake smile and
the episode comes to an end
this was a really crazy episode that hit
so many points along the way and what i
liked about it was that it feels like
they might actually do it they might
really do this thing they might really
give this character and story a proper
ending but everything is still on the
table there were moments in this episode
where i felt a hundred percent sure that
harrison is going to kill dexter in the
finale but then angela still feels like
a real threat especially with this
letter at the end so it's really hard to
say and harrison is so back and forth
which makes sense considering what he
learned about his father in this idea of
a dark passenger throughout this episode
but like i was saying in one minute i'm
thinking he's all in this is what he's
been looking for and then in the next
i'm thinking oh my god he's gonna kill
dexter i think it's important to think
about how dexter presents what he does
to his son the way he sees himself he's
expecting that someone with those same
violent tendencies will understand and
he's jumped to thinking that harrison is
exactly the same as him and the only
chance that either one of them would
ever have is the code and you can't
forget that deb is actually right this
is what he wants and that is bound to
cloud his judgment i think the exchange
where they were talking about vigilante
[ __ ] is something that's worth
remembering harrison could definitely
bring trouble kurt's way through legal
channels if he went and told his story
to the police they would likely discover
everything else in the process and then
he would be imprisoned and possibly
executed for his crimes the key here is
that dexter knows he can't let him do
that because he knows he'll be exposed
for killing matt and that's not exactly
the way that he sold it to him then
there's the big moment when dexter
finally confesses that he killed wiggles
and trinity and in that moment harrison
clearly accepts what he does later when
he actually sees him cutting up the body
though i can't help but think about
harry the idea of killing people who
slip through the cracks of the legal
system sounds like a plausible way to
channel this impulse towards violence
but seeing it in action is a totally
different thing being able to do that is
what separates dexter from everyone else
and understanding that was enough to
lead to harry's suicide harry thought he
created a monster and he regretted it to
the point of taking his own life it's
not likely that dexter would think that
he did something wrong let alone feel
remorse and it's not clear that harrison
would be able to take lives and feel
okay with it the same way that dexter
does i guess it all comes down to the
fact that it sounds like a logical
solution to the issue of dexter wanting
to kill people but things get more
complicated when you think about what a
monster he actually is i'll have to go
back and re-watch it to take a closer
look at those scenes but it felt like
there was some separation between what
harrison was saying and what he was
experiencing and there are a lot of ways
his perspective could change especially
if he found out that his mother was
killed because of what dexter was doing
in relation to trinity remember he told
him here that he killed trinity for what
he did to his mother and that's not the
truth or the whole story a lot of people
guessed that molly was already dead and
my thinking about that was that i
thought that her information would play
a larger role so i was happy with the
way that it played out considering that
they now have her recorder and her
camera which i'm sure will be important
going forward it was a pretty good turn
that kurt got the letter to angela even
after he was dead and now it all makes
sense on why he sent the screw that he
did to dexter now it looks like dexter
has a trophy from his kill and
considering that his cabin was just
burnt down people are going to be
investigating that scene and that
titanium doesn't melt that screw may
cause him a problem plus matt's rifle
might still be under the fire pit i'm
not sure about that one i think it's
also pretty likely that harrison will
have blood on his boot i'm gonna leave
this video here and then i'll follow it
up with one breaking down the teaser and
talking through all the theories because
there's a lot going on and i want to
hear what you guys have to say because
there's a lot to think about so please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already check back in a day or so for
the next video and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon